fais-le
Ce n'est rien de tout ça, il n'y a pas eu d'agitation
C'était très confortable et social
La distanciation est bien respectée
Il est demandé aux gens d’utiliser des masques.
Les œufs sont fraîchement préparés à la main
Utilisez Sanitizer Sangh et spécial
après avoir fait une chose et l'avoir laissée sur l'autre siège
Passager parce que pour courir la vie
tu dois souvent sortir de la maison
Je ne peux pas rester longtemps à la maison
Si oui, alors c'est une bonne initiative du gouvernement.
Si nous voulons vivre, nous devons travailler.
Et pour ça aussi beaucoup de MRP.
c'est une bonne initiative
La connaissance préalable du cinquième mois Neetu Pa
crayon à quartz
cette journée réussie à Modi Padma Chandra Kushwaha
Taille de la population en
Jetez un oeil, quelqu'un grandit
Parce que les gens n'ont plus si peur
[musique]